[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenos días a todos como descubrir tu
propio camino mi nombre es quin a ver si
yo soy dj productor de música e
ingeniero mecánico
mi razón de dar tres esta presentación
es para inspirarlos para que logren
seguir su propia creatividad y su
intuición en el rompecabezas que es la
vida
esta es mi historia les voy a dar tres
ejemplos para que no importa la edad que
tengan puedan entender el concepto de lo
que les quiero decir
primero tengan en consideración que
siempre por una que ustedes intenten
hacer las cosas bien y todo lo que
quieran hacer siempre se van a encontrar
con pequeños pasos de fracaso en la vida
pero no se deben de desilusionar tienen
que simplemente identificar el problema
analizarlo ver cómo lo pueden arreglar y
cómo pueden aprender de él y muchas
veces aprendemos más de las cosas malas
que de las cosas buenas
cuando tenía 10 años por ejemplo puerto
rico el fin los veranos pero siempre
hace mucho calor y recuerdo que tenía
una vecina que siempre hacía el inverse
pero yo los 10 años no tenía dinero ya
no trabajaba a los 10 años lo que pasa
recuerdo que mi padre en algún momento
compró un printer y una computadora
trasteando con ella decidí hacer como
como flyers chiquitito
desde casa lagartijos por una peseta
bien raro no tenía diez años que pasa el
donde nosotros vivíamos había el bosque
san patricio esta va a ser que por eso
todas las casas siempre tenían un montón
de lagartijo y cosas y pues para mi
sorpresa los vecinos me empezaron a
llamar y me pasé el recuerdo fue bien
gracioso pero recuerdo que los veranos
pues muchas veces los vecinos me
llamaban yo iba a sacar lagartijo
resultado afuera me daba una peseta y va
a la casa de otra vecina y conseguido el
limbo
pero aprendí de eso ya como cuando tenía
13 años fue que empecé a descubrir mi
pasión por la música ha dicho que haría
producir música ya como tenía como unos
17 años que estaba ya en las hay siempre
que las hay todo el mundo iba a la playa
siempre me echaban a triste la música tú
porque para aquel entonces yo era el día
de las hadas y tocaba los planes los
panas y toda la cosa que sucede para que
el tiempo estamos hablando 2004 por ahí
más o menos
no habían bocinas bluetooth grande no de
toda esta cosa no existía que pasa
cuantos han visto por ahí en la playa
las neveras estas con bocinas que hacen
con bale que pasa en el 2004 más o menos
fue que entonces yo decidí inventar una
neverita de playa con bocina ya que mi
primera patente salí en otro el más
enseñado a la neverita salí en el gane
dos ferias empresariales en sábados
gigantes con don francisco enseñando la
neverita
bien raro pero sí
en este entre otras cosas el punto es
que para que el entonces a pesar de que
tenía mi patente
la gente empezó a hacer copias de lo que
era el concepto no nos llegaban
exactamente a lo que yo he diseñado pero
pasé por un proceso de frustración
depresión no volví a la playa como por
tres años porque no quería encontrarme
ninguna y sentía que había perdido como
cuatro años de mi vida de research y
toda esta búsqueda tratar de crear un
invento
decidí seguir para que el entonces
estaba empezando estaba al principio de
la universidad y mi plan era dicho
quiero producir música los fines de
semana estudiar ingeniería mecánica
porque era de luego meter más clases de
piloto porque yo quería ser astronauta
pero qué pasa luego descubrí otro
fracaso ya como a mitad de mi carrera de
la universidad de ingeniería mecánica y
cuando estoy haciendo búsqueda para
enviar en resumen y ver qué pasos tengo
que seguir descubrí que para que el
entonces para tu ser astronauta tienes
que medir menos de seis pies y tener 20
20 de visión
yo dije adiós hasta aquí llegué
sentí que se me partió el corazón porque
yo dije contra esto es lo que yo quiero
hacer lo que llevo años haciendo
research y buscando y trabajando porque
yo quería ser astronauta pero tal vez la
visión yo sé espejuelos tal vez la puedo
corregir pero qué hago con los seis pies
2012 y 3 que me cortó un pie este y para
dentro de toda esta depresión y todo lo
que pasó luego salió la idea de entonces
de crear en lo que es el traje de kim
como tal para el 2009 yo empecé a
trabajar en univisión y conociendo mucha
gente que trabaja en televisión descubrí
que muchos de ellos cuando están frente
a las cámaras
ellos se transforman entran en
personajes ya no estoy diciendo que
físicamente se vistan sino que pues
entran en personaje que sucede para que
entonces yo estaba terminando ingeniería
mecánica y dije bueno voy a crearme un
personaje para televisión
entonces pues termine colocar el traje
el primer la primera versión del traje
fue la del 2009 luego 2012 2018 hacer un
traje me toma como un año y medio es un
proceso bien largo
pero si tengo un traje necesito una nave
entonces empecé a hacer los djs busqué y
utilizo para tocar como si fueran naves
espaciales para tratar de convertir a
toda esta parte mala que me sucedió que
era lo que yo quería hacer es
simplemente me dijeron no lo puedes
hacer porque naciste mal por buenas y
muy alto no nací con 2020
qué pasa
para mi sorpresa después de todo de
seguir este camino esta dirección
termine compartiendo tarima con gente
que yo jamás pensé que iba a compartir
daddy yankee wisin y yandel
jennifer lópez estival yuki sin
mencionar no mucho más y con un montón
de clientes que
ya de compañías grandes y reconocidas
una sorpresa no me lo esperaba
lo que les quiero decir es que la vida
es como si fuera un rompecabezas
a los que les gustan los videojuegos y
todo esto deben de saber que usualmente
tú tienes unas piezas y tienes que hacer
esto hacer esto otro mezclar estas dos
cosas para entonces poder dar el próximo
paso
quiero hacer una reflexión con ustedes
para que entiendan bien lo que les
quiero decir por favor pónganse de pie
un momento
para que me entiendan primero relax
piensen intentando no pensar en muchas
cosas tranquilo
tokens a las manos hagan esto
si entonces te sientes ustedes están
vivos ahora aquí en este momento el
tiempo pasa a la vida uno solamente
tiene una una sola vida no cierra los
ojos un momento
piensen
y lo que ustedes quieren ser en la vida
cuál es su propósito que están cuál es
tu misión en la vida
piensa que obstrucciones o qué camino te
están impidiendo ahora mismo hacer eso
que tú quieres hacer
piensa en
si tienes que estudiar algo te tienes
que enviar una aplicación para conseguir
un trabajo es lo que quiere si tienes
que inscribirte en una universidad para
estudiar algo que tú quieres piensa en
esa meta piensa en que te está
impidiendo o cómo puedes resolver este
rompecabezas para que en tu situación
actual pueda dar estos pasos y a baby
steps ir paso a paso paso a paso a
lograr tus metas
la vida una disfrutarla hacerla bien y
no olviden siempre de cumplir sus sueños
gracias
[Aplausos]